Speaker 1: Welcome back, everybody, to the
David Pakman Show. Luke Beasley here filling
in for David today while he is away taking care
of his new baby. If you like what you see here,
definitely go subscribe to my YouTube
channel by searching Luke Beasley on
YouTube. If you want to get the video form or
Luke Beasley on any podcast listening platform,
if you just want to listen. Father's Day was
over the weekend, as I'm sure you're aware,
and a lot of people spend Father's
Day doing different things, but
things like spending time with family or if you're
a father, maybe you have your family surround you
and give you appreciation. Go out barbecuing,
whatever you do something fun like that. But not
not if you're the former president. Donald Trump
trumps Father's Day, angrily sending out messages
on his social media site. True social, just
absolutely losing it. So here is the first
sweet Father's Day message from Donald J.
Trump. The highly partizan unsullied are trying
to create. I'm not going to do that the whole
time. Are trying to create a fake narrative for
whatever reason, but only with evil intention
that he knew the election was stolen. This is
completely false. I felt the election was rigged
and stolen have from the very beginning and have
only gotten stronger in that belief with time and
large amounts of additional evidence and proof.
In my mind, I have and have had no question,
and many people would be willing to attest
big, bold, all caps all throughout that.
But the answer likes don't want to hear
them. Okay, well, he started off strong Father's
Day, but then. Then he cools off. Maybe now. Well,
let's see. You're ready for this witch hunt.
That was just it. All caps, which. That's it.
It's too much former president, surely. Now
he's going to wrap it up, enjoy his Father's
Day. Spend some time eating a Big Mac with a
vodka. No, I am leading in every poll by a lot,
and the Democrats are doing everything they can to
change that, even if it's another Russia, Russia,
Russia hoax, Mueller scam, impeachment, waste of
time or whatever, the same lying people saying
the same kind of thing. I only want to. And
then in all caps, make America great again. So
to the polling thing, he is doing a lot better in
polling than he probably should be. That's crazy.
Out of the last four he's beating Biden into
so Biden's winning in two he's winning into
not completely accurate what he said but it's
still there's some truth to it that he is leading
in recent polls that's frightening. And next, he
addresses the Georgia phone call that happened,
of course, where he asked the secretary
of state to find him 11,000 whatever votes
that were to help him flip the election to
being a win for him. My phone call to the
Georgia secretary of state with many other
people, including numerous lawyers, knowing
knowingly on the line was absolutely perfect
and appropriate. Yes, it was a perfect call.
And so it was the second call for which The
Washington Post was forced to do a major and
somewhat embarrassing retraction. Thank you.
Okay, so the Georgia call is fine. Even I was
trying to pressure a secretary of state to find
11,000 something votes that would help me win the
election even though I didn't. Perfect phone call.
Well, finally, to wrap it up, I have to be fair.
He did say at the very end, I want to wish
everyone a beautiful Father's Day filled
with peace, love and compassion. No, he didn't
say that at all. I have so many witnesses to
everything good that that's ended the Zoe. I have
so many witnesses to everything good. Hmm. But the
highly partizan and one sided onslaught committee
of political hacks has not interest in hearing,
has not interest in hearing or seeing them. This
witch hunt could all be ended quickly if they did.
So a little bit of a typo there and not interest.
They have not interest. Very fascinating. But
instead of hanging out with his children where
they can say, you're a great father, they can lie
and tell them that Eric Don, Ivanka. No. Instead
he's maybe he was with them, I don't know. But not
spending quality time because instead he was
ranting and raving about all of those things.